hey guys Felicia and Eric from fandango
movie clips and what did we just see we
just saw the first public screening of
furious 7 it is 3am the lights are out
on the marquee but we walked out and we
were like we have to tell you guys first
what the deal is with I one of 2015's
biggest movies Furious 7 where do you
think spoiler free of cost spoiler I
think at this point it's a comedy it's
pretty much a comedy it's got a
ridiculous script those stupid
one-liners implausible stunts there is
no way any of them could've survived
those stunts they don't even adhere to
laws of physics but you know what it was
so much I was insanity it was so much
fun some of the action sequences in this
film I think we're some of the best I've
ever seen in my life you've seen in the
trailer where the cars are kind of
parachuting out of the plane well you
guys have no idea that sequence is like
35 minutes long and it just starts there
and it gets crazier and crazier that
this whole film just gets crazier and
crazier and crazier as it goes along it
is just insane I say this is probably
the manliest movie I have ever seen a
lot of muscles a lot of fistfights a lot
of explosions of course fast cars sexy
girls it's everything you want from this
series it's just over-the-top enough it
is and you know what if you're a fan of
this franchise it really ties all the
films together in a really fun way and
the finale is kind of old school fast
and furious and just so cool i mean the
audience for this film went ballistic
for this movie i've never seen an
audience go as ballistic as they did so
this is a film that you want to see
opening weekend with those audiences
with that those friends that are that
love this franchise that want to see it
right away because it is that's it
enhances the experience of course we
won't give away anything about the paul
walker and how they traded his character
but i will say they did it so well and
seamless it was perfect it was it was
seamless you know and and I
just I loved what they did with paul
walker and you never at any time you
know I think his brother has helped out
finishing his roles but he's not town
you can't tell it all I mean this whole
movie is Paul Walker so I'm Eric yeah
I'm Alicia and you know what this one's
for Paul dude wherever you are right now
you done good and we miss you